première source rémois mais paul aaa
et oula ça démarre très fort
moi je rigole ça démarre peut-être trop
vite
je ne peux pas changer sur vite démarrer
vite ça concerne guillaume genton
et ben ça suffit quand vous allez savoir
son surnom d' aller vous dire on
comprend sa tenue
millions soit 6 très étrange entre
guillaume genton et le journaliste
people jordan de luxe pour preuve jordan
surnomme guillaume ma petite [ __ ]
ouvertement et c'est vrai qu'il a dit
également c'est vrai moi bout mais ça
c'est totalement vrai moi j'ai eu jordan
sur twitter je ne sais quoi cette
histoire j'ai des bruits qui me viennent
à mes oreilles comment toi tu peux
parler comme ça de guillaume il me dit
écoute rentre pas là dedans sinon je
montre les captures d'écran et je montre
les photos guillaume en voyou me mange
dans la main et il paraîtrait que
guillaume luyt l'averse 1500 euros par
mois qu'ils se taisent non moi
ça va ça va de plus en plus loin
elle avait vécu là heureusement que ça
une avocate
donc là on parle de raquettes ouvertes
[Rires]
non mais ça c'est le foot daniel moreau
nous parlera bien sûr de son addiction
aux cacolac
mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu une histoire
avec jordan de luxe c'était très
passionnel six mois à toi bats on avait
une histoire est au bout de six mois il
m'a quittée il s'est tourné vers
d'autres q ha pardon vers d'autres
[Rires]
cieux liés aux téléspectateurs moi je ne
les tiens plus
l'arrivée il sort y est c'était le
premier de la classe non mais sans
déconner on dirait qu'ils ont dirait
qu'ils travaillent au nom mais je fais
pas ou d'ailleurs
non mais franchement ressaisissez vous
baladant métier magnifique alors elle
c'est une belle chemise oui c'est une
belle semaine venant sentimentale oui
bah oui ma mère de s'habiller souvent
comme ça qu'on a travaillé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on
croyait sa mère travaillait dans un seul
non merci il a plus de respect envers
quoi mais c'est même plus
à les marier malgré où j'obtiens aaa
mais pour arrondir ses fins de mois
benjamin castaldi ferait payer à des
téléspectateurs un pack coulisses dans
lequel il promet une visite plus une
photo avec lui à regarder mais non mais
ça c'est vrai encore hier je l'aï vu
avec 5,6 téléspectateurs en coulisse non
mais ces oreillers le pack 25 euros 5
euros la photo
il propose ainsi knickers dédicacé pour
10 au
cerceau même castaldi enfin pour
franchement gérez vous me connaissez oui
mais juste
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable ça démarre très pas ou
alors où là tous les jours guillaume
genton pour un malin plaisir à faire des
tékés son chien juste devant les bureaux
de si
c'est vrai les trois chiens alors s'il
habite à 7 km de la fatwa dispose chien
gens tombent sur ce valérie bénaïm c'est
vrai quoi les équipes ont réussies à la
cheville en plus de votre immeuble alors
pour la petite anecdote cyril ça m'a
interpellé quand même cette affaire
puisqu'il habite l'om à sept kilomètres
dont je me dis quand même pourquoi tu
prends ton chien tulameen à sept
kilomètres de là pour ensuite le faire
déféquer vraiment l'immeuble de ton
patron j'ai appelé un copain psy pour
essayer de voir comment on faisait que
vous donniez franchement il a il a
analysé la sphère est en fête guillaume
à un petit complexe et il arrive est en
fait à la fois d'infériorité de
supériorité et le fait de faire ça c'est
tout simplement qu'ils vous chie à la
gueule
je le prends comme un acte d'amitié
et de comprendre comme un hommage en
fait grâce à vous je nourris mon chien
il vous le rend à sa manière tous les
jours
rappelle donald angers chez dante et
chaussons
s'appelle donalda les pensions ou bien
de tpm paix laurent fontaine a dit aux
producteurs c'est une bonne idée de
mettre les gens beaux à la droite de
cyril comme le rallye c'est moi d'être
les moins beaux à gauche comme daniel
oui je sais mon grand père est moche que
qu'on
sait comment les
piqueurs études de leurs maux c'est ta
jalousie pour mathieu et notamment son
physique de rêve et c'est plutôt ouais
ouais mais mais mais c'est ça c'est ça
ton problème tu pars tu trouves
tu pas reconduit on vous a vu ce qui est
dit qu on est moche
les réponses à rien et elle est
magnifique médaille a comme moi le mot
non
elle ne vous n'êtes pas moche non mais
ne riez pas moi je il propose au choix
mais c'est autre chose c'est une autre
proposition c'est comme dans le jeune
jean luc reichmann il ya deux bonnes
réponses et puis à autre sur une autre
oui ces autres et y voilà bahia la glace
des hommes femmes autres autres mais
voilà mais en tout cas cette magnifique
et il faut dit lui dans les pays de
l'est a et ça c'est un énorme bosseur il
a le secret
il est magnifique dans les dents serrées
on l'a pris pour mickey rourke non mais
c'est vrai parmi ses rangs vous a pris
pour micro
car on s'est retrouvés l'un à côté de
l'autre et je peux vous dire que
[Rires]
yahvé mickey rourke et mickey plus qu il
a class elle dit vous êtes avec un bar
qu'est-ce que vous êtes attaqués à
valérie benaïm
vous êtes attaque à valérie bénaïm
amiable valérie bénaïm n'est valérie
bénaïm
c'est closer dans le nord de la grèce
antique
valérie à de sérieux problèmes sexuels
dans son couple
avants néo preuve en est avec un bouquin
trouvé sur son bureau photos à l'appui
la retraite sexuelle n'aura pas lieu
certes on va quand même offrir ce livre
à danielle moores
si bien dire il est sur mon bureau
maintenant c'est vrai battant qu'il est
que sur votre bureau ça va
c'est vrai que c'est un problème pour
révéler riche je vous le dise valérie
elle parle beaucoup avec delphine
wespiser amis d'amérique puisque leur
mecque où la
demande et j'ai surpris comme combien de
combien de fois tu es tu fais l'amour
avec avec les crocs j'ai donc des films
ne répond pas déjà c'est vrai que déjà
la phrase mais on a fait l'amour avec
route est déjà
toute une armée c'est bon merci voilà
donc des films répond une fois par
semaine non une fois par semaine oui
allez vous dire c'est parce que moi moi
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins
et elle a avoué qu'elle faisait sa une
fois par six mois non en fait ils sont
mais qui rappellent qu'ils s'appellent
patrick que tout le monde l'appelle
patoche qu'en fait qu'ils s'appellent
patoche
non je vais répondre à sa main que
effectivement je reçois énormément de
livres qu'alexandra la gentillesse de
même apporté dans l'émission si tu avais
vu la curiosité intellectuelle d'ouvrir
tu aurais vu que ce livre que j'ai reçu
je me suis permis de le dédicacer à ta
femme
[Applaudissements]
à vingt-deux j'embrasse et va
certainement être avec son amant pendant
que
c'est vrai qu'il ya des avantages à
faire illusion direction mais c'est vrai
qu'on mérite non mais j'en rigolerais
grande écoute la fat ou oui elle est
tranquille elle voilà elle voit la
gueule de regarder
aller tranquillement avec jean rouger
non mais c'est vrai après on
n'a pas tous les jours de fête
voilà et tranquille
à l affaire mais l'institut très tôt
la très grosse cookies également onlive
aux dénonciations qui concerne
régine
guillaume genton dit régine s'est
inventé des déboires avec la justice
pour faire appel alors alice mais n'a en
dehors des heures de tournage géraldine
maillet c'est vous c'est exact et je le
déplore nous aussi depuis que le
réalisme est venu ici sûreté pmp d'abord
en tant qu'intervenante guillaume n'est
pas bien lieu mais fébrile alors quand
elle est arrivée comme chroniqueuse hier
alors là il était carrément agitée et
après l'émission il a poursuivi dans les
couloirs de manière plutôt agressive
mais j'ai entendu des mots et
si c'est bon il vient d'insulter sa mère
à bien savoir qu'on l'appelle petit plus
c'est vrai à mort jeudi comme un drame
non monsieur vous plaît c'est quand même
quelqu'un je n'ai pas envie termine dans
faites entrer l'accusé
non mais c'est vrai voilà donc s'il te
plaît des photos non mais j'ai entendu
je suis dans la merde point permis eh
ben moi s'il te plaît non mais c'est
vrai vous ennuis avec la justice j'ai eu
une contravention pour stationnement
gênant et j'ai besoin d'un avocat talent
on à défendre c'est tout mais vous
faites vous faites ça alors je fais ça
mais il n'a pas dit toute la vérité
alors il ya le secret professionnel
m'empêche d'en parler alors ici
[Rires]
l'un des six déjà n'y a pas de
professionnels a
aucun secret ce qu'il oublie de dire
c'est que mon téléphone d'habitude et en
mode avion pendant toute la nuit j'avais
oublié de le mettre en mode avion et
donc ils sonnaient à 3 heures du matin
m'a appelé 400
normand voyer mais venir de concéder
urgent alors je n'en dirai pas plus a
inclus un poney mais je
prenais un bonhomme je me prenais un peu
un bonnet ça promet ça inclut un poney
aimé maeght arrêter des permis à points
pour les poneys non non mais vous
restez dans le droit chinois il vous
appelle c'est louche cette histoire de
contraventions c'est un terrible à
battre c'est un terrible mal qui nous
ronge alary vous avez une eau de la
police la plus proche de chez vous
non mais ça n'est
pas les paluches il est très très loin
le m'occuper de lui dernière pukki à
houla
oula
alors moi je peux pas les lire c'est
daniel moreau auteur de cette poule qui
valent à lire ohlala daniel moreau
mettez vos lunettes
celle qui a balancé
regardez bien
mais alors en a dit ouais ouais non mais
franchement avec l'émulateur
secrétaire à domicile qu'en mon nom me
rester chez eux
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça ne m'amuse pas de le dire mais la
vérité à vertou la vérité qui compte
macaskill
était en loge et lisez bien fort j'ai
déjà été en fait dans les toilettes et
vous quel est notre loge alors les
toilettes donc voilà je je ne suis il a
dit je ne suis pas du tout attiré pas
afida turner mais bon je lui mettrais
bien un petit coup quand même mal
c'est vrai
si la fable benjamin castaldi l'on
regarde
je vais lui donner tout de suite pour la
fin de benjamin castadi si elle me
regarde va s'afficher au bas de l'écran
le numéro d'un serrurier
a bien sûr changé toutes les serrures
avant qu'il ne rende ce soir si chère à
castanet vous êtes bien sûr le bienvenue
à la maison
à juste qui a entendu ça laurent
fontaine quand je crois gilles verdez
assure gérard dine et régine c'est moi
je n'ai pas entendu en loge l'entente
est dans le couloir
ce qui veut dire qu'il aurait dit deux
fois il a même si vous avez un truc à
mes yeux n'en croyaient pas leurs
oreilles je voudrais bien une salade de
nibards
bac à
savoir la quête de castaldi bien entendu
quand tout devient rouge chez lui
c'est qu'il ya un souci alors je
t'embrasse bien entendu tu trouveras les
coordonnées d'un bon avocat est ici et
on embrasse bien sûr l'emploi